One final password thing. I know I promised the last one was
the final one, but we've got to mention this. We know how
to store a password securely on the server. We still have this
issue that if you type in a password, remember how when we
did the forms, I showed you that you could type in password
in a password text box. You know and, and it looks like
little, little circles or little asterisks. And that even when you, when
you submit this in the URL, you could still see, remember we
saw q equal to hunter 2 before when we're playing around
with that. Submitting a form to go back to our trusted
picture, you know if you're submitting this password to these servers,
the password is actually sent in clear text over the internet.
So you're storing the password securely on your server. If your
database gets stolen, you know you're covered pretty much. But the
problem is when the user logs in, they're actually sending this
password [INAUDIBLE] of the internet. So if you really, really care about
that, about having the password encrypted the whole way
so some bad guy in the middle can't just,
you know, sniff the password off the wire, you
use HTTPS. And all HTTPs is, its just like HTTP
except it is encrypted over SSL. That means this
whole communication is encrypted, so this man in the
middle in theory, unless he's hacked very sign, and
they never get hacked, can't see what's being transmitted over
the wire. So it's all gobbledegook to him.
So anyway, that's what HTTPS is for. And if
you really are, if you're building something that's secure,
you know, perhaps not a blog, but you know
Gmail for example, you want to be using HTTPs.
And then you've got secure transmission from the browser
to the servers, and you've got secure passwords on
the servers. And you're in a reasonably good setup.